okay last question today and it's a
doozy hey David I think I got any
politics is great can you change my mind
it depends on what you mean by identity
politics okay
I've said before recognizing the
importance of identity is great we
should all do it okay
our identity brings a particular
experience and point of view we exist in
the world as people of certain gender we
exist in the world as people of certain
age people of certain ethnic backgrounds
and religions to pretend that identity
provides no window into policy and ideas
and is relevant to politics that would
be crazy okay so of course identity
matters and we need to account for
identity listen to people on the basis
of the perspective that their identity
gives them identity as a trump card to
silence to exclude or marginalize other
views that's where it becomes a problem
and earlier in the week we talked about
identity politics as a point of view for
arguing bias with David Webb David Webb
this black Tea Party guy who during his
show was told that his view is
influenced by his white privilege by a
legal analyst who didn't know that she
was talking to a black guy and that just
benefits the right right I mean the the
the playing of that type of identity
politics by the left and it's not a huge
issue but it exists and so I mentioned
that it exists and it's not a good thing
it helps to the right galvanize and
coalesce voters around even worse
identity ideas much of trumps success
with white identity politics the
alt-right the identitarian know that
entire thing the threat of the status of
middle-class White's for example all of
that was seen by them I'm not saying I
agree it was seen by them as a necessary
response to left-wing identity politics
it's much exaggerated obviously but it
doesn't help the left so if you love
identity politics because you
think identity is important and we
should evaluate ideas by understanding
that someone's identity can give us
insight into what makes sense I'm right
there with you but if you support the
sort of identity politics games that
I've identified as completely
destructive to the left show me how they
benefit us show me how they work I've
not seen any evidence of that we have a
great bonus show for you today become a
member become a patron and you'll get
instant access otherwise you'll have to
wait till Monday for the next show